Bona tarda! Dimarts 28 de juliol, fa pocs segons que he acabat de gravar la part final de l'últim vídeo que he pujat.
I, bueno, el vídeo del dia 141, no el de Catalans Sense Fronteres, perquè no sé a qui pujaré abans, bueno, és igual,
que comença el vídeo dels recados a Tbilisi. Encara no tinc el micròfon i és de les primeres coses que hauria de fer,
però abans, com estic a prop del barri antic, vaig a mirar a veure si trobo postals.
Aquestes són bastant xules. Mireu que té una forma com molt allargada. A veure quant costen.
M'han fet descompte, m'han fet descompte, no per les xules que us he ensenyat, sinó per unes altres que també eren guais, però no tan guais.
I era 1,1 laris, que són 37 cèntims. No està malament, però és sol pagar menys per les postals.
Quan els he dit que anava a buscar una altra cosa, em faig com...
Però tu, escolta, tinc moltes opcions, és la primera tenda que traurava.
Torno a ser a l'habitació. Al final he hagut de passar a parlar-ho i agafar la primera oferta que m'han donat, 1,1 per cada postal.
Per tant, m'he gastat 576 laris. Bueno, mira, està bé.
Hi ha bastanta varietat. Hi ha així una mica com amb dibuixets.
Hi ha fotos reals, com aquesta d'aquí, això que és el Memories Chronicles of Georgia, el mapa, això és que és una mica com...
Bueno, dibuix digital, podríem dir. Aquí uns gatets amb jincalis.
No estan malament, trobo que no estan malament, són modernes. Ara comprar els micròfons.
Bueno, he vingut a la botiga de Gamers. Últim cop que m'escolteu malament, perquè ja tinc els micròfons.
Malauradament, he hagut de comprar l'únic abasso que tenien, que és la Combo, que té tots els receptors.
Però, bueno, seleccionaré els receptors que necessito jo, USB tipus C, i la resta, fora.
I els posaré la capsa meva, vull dir, la capsa aquesta tampoc necessito.
Un dispendi una mica inútil de calés, perquè...
Ja et dic, la versió barata seria més millor, però no la tenen.
500 laris, que són 170 euros.
Però era l'única manera. Era l'única manera, era l'única manera.
Era l'única manera d'aconseguir-los. Ja està.
Ja ho tenim, ja ho tenim.
Ara hauria de trobar la copisteria per aquí.
Però molts cops...
El Google s'equivoca i et diu que aquí no hi ha copisteria, i no hi és, eh?
A l'altre en volem cobrar 20 euros per imprimir 20 pàgines en forma d'etiqueta.
Home, no fotem.
Doncs aquí, a un carreró, és on està la copisteria.
Copisteria en georgià, o bueno, aquí a Tbilisi, les copisteries es diuen xerox.
No sé per què, bueno...
Neusat una mica, 10 euros. 10 euros per 20 pàgines...
Ok, va bé, ok.
Arribo tard, a la meva cita amb en Roger.
A Tbilisi és molt còmode moure's amb taxi, perquè és barat, però encara és més barat el metro,
i s'ha d'agafar el metro si veniu a Tbilisi, perquè és brutal, lo profund que és.
Mireu, aquí dalt quan queda, i aquí baix.
Està fet a prova de bombes, literalment.
A baix, a l'andana, no tens res de cobertura, perquè clar, és que estàs tan al fons...
Bueno, només és una parada, però tinc mandra de caminar i vaig tard, així que agafo el metro.
A veure, aquí és.
Hola senyor. Hola.
Què tal? Roger, vols sortir el vídeo?
I tant. Ja és massa tard, per dir que no.
Hello, hola. Gammers jove.
Nombre? Nom? Name?
Ella. Ella.
Bueno, tio, na, cita una birra.
Estic... He needs a beer.
Estic... So tired.
I need something to drink. Estic... Estic un dia molt d'això, tio.
La volta al món a peu, dia 242.
No són hores, són les 8 del matí. No són hores després de...
La farra. No, no va ser farra, no vam anar de festa, però bueno, vam estar allà al bar, no sé què...
Després vam anar a sopar, vaig tornar a les tantes.
I hi ha un seguidor, que es diu Xavier, que m'ha comprat uns mitjons i me'ls ha portat i m'ha dit
ens veiem avui, o sigui, demà, m'ho va dir, ahir, al meu hotel, te'ls dono i esmorzem junts.
Ok, clar. Què has de dir, no? Molt agraït.
I res, tu, a matinar una mica.
I res, tu, a matinar una mica. I res, tu, a matinar una mica.
Hola, Xavier. Hola, què tal?
Què m'has portat?
Doncs mira, mitjons. Doncs moltíssimes
gràcies, tu. Ho necessitava, eh?
Perquè aquí em costava trobar mitjons
fins... D'acord.
Vaig a corrents abans de sortir a buscar-te'ls
al... Ets un crac. I què has vingut aquí
de turisme? No, veníem a fer muntanya, també.
Ah, sí? Ostres. I ens vam fer un paio de dies
de turisme, però se'ns anaven cap al Cauques.
Uau.
Som tota una colla d'injusts de les
seies de Sant Just. Ostres, i què anava a fer, exactament?
No m'hi miren ni els... No ho saps, eh?
No m'hi miren ni els noms.
Bé, no, però us encantarà.
Us encantarà. Jo vaig a estar...
Fent trek vuit dies, també.
Molt bé. Doncs què, anem a esmorzar?
Sí, esperaré si baixen els companys.
Ok. Perfecte.
Bueno, rifenys.
Gent de Sant Just, aquí.
Hola.
Hola, Trenc.
Que marxo per...
Gràcies per l'esmorzar, eh?
D'acord, doncs el que tinc són un munt de mitjons
de running
dalt de Calón.
Està perfecte. És que aquí, a Georgia,
em costa molt trobar mitjons fins.
I, bueno, jo normalment
ja sabeu que m'agrada portar molt poc pes,
per tant, porto dos parells de mitjons.
Un per caminar i un per
descansar. Però en aquest cas els portaré
tots a sobre, a pesar del pes,
perquè jo crec que en els propers
mesos no
trobaré res per comprar mitjons.
O sigui, en mig de Tadjikistan, si se'm trenquen uns mitjons
pot ser un drama, perquè no ho puc comprar. Per tant,
els portaré
i si quan se'm vagin trencant,
que se'm trencaran, els aniré canviant.
Pugim un moment a l'hotel
a fer un number two, que diuen
en anglès, i després anem a Correus.
Són les 11 i 20. He estat a l'hotel
un munt d'estona pel tema
de les aduanes del sac de dormir.
He darrere un sac de dormir que ve de Polònia,
per tant, ha de pagar aduanes
i, bueno, a ella va ser un percal
per aconseguir el taxpayer,
el codi
de pagador
fiscal georgià,
perquè, clar, no sóc resident,
i ara per pagar el govern
he d'obrir-me, o sigui, he de tenir un compte
georgià, un compte de banc georgià. Estem bojos?
I dic, no, és impossible,
és critària, no, jo me'n vaig del país en dos dies.
Però, bueno, per si a cas,
havia obert, o he intentat obrir un compte
al Bank of Georgia,
pensant que, bueno, ja em respondran d'aquí
cinc dies, saps?, és impossible. I no, no, m'acaben
de respondre ara en pocs minuts
que vagi a una oficina del Bank de Georgia
que m'obren el compte.
Una odissea, eh? Avui estem a dia 29
i el límit per rebre'l
és avui
o demà, perquè ja el dia següent
ja me'n vaig a Uzbekistà.
A veure, a veure...
Aconseguit!
Tinc, no una, sinó
dues targetes del Bank of Georgia.
He aconseguit pagar, també,
han rebassat, han rebassat
els impostos
del tema de la duana,
però encara no s'ha acabat això, perquè ara l'he enviat
al PDF, amb el comprovant de pagament
a DHL, ells han de fer
altres gestions,
després hauré de pagar
al receptor, o sigui, no,
a la persona que me l'enviï
60 gels, que són,
bueno, i a l'IVA,
bueno, en fi, no, no sé, no sé,
no sé què ho faré.
Sabeu una cosa bona de tenir compte,
al Banc Georgià, que ara
podré canviar la forma de pagament
d'Spotify, i en comptes
de pagar 12 euros al mes, com estic fent ara,
pagaré 5.
L'Spotify a Georgia val 5 euros al mes.
I això, ja, a menys que em canseguin
la compta al Banc de Georgia, ja serà
per tota la vida.
M'estalviaré, al llarg de la meva vida,
centenars d'euros amb Spotify.
Val, ara sí, anem a correus,
són les 12 i pico, jo no sé si em donarà temps
a fer tot el que vull fer avui, eh?
No sé si em donarà temps.
D'acord, ha sigut
car, però ha sigut
més fàcil del previst. A una altra oficina de correus
m'havien dit que era impossible que em donessin
tantes postals en una sola
oficina. Llavors, el que vaig fer
va ser a Bojorna i comprar-ne 200,
perquè no en teníem més.
I aquí, sí, sí, me les han donat.
320 segells,
600 i pico euros
sumats als, no sé, 400
de l'altre dia, pues jo què sé, sí,
poc més de 1.000 euros,
en total, sí, sí.
I les postals, vos ahir us vaig dir
quan m'han costat, sumeu, pues sí, sí,
el més, el 1.000,
1.000, no sé, 1.200.
Una passada,
aquest mes, una passada.
Però bueno, tu, l'aixeta,
m'ajudeu molt, si voleu, ja sabeu,
aixeta.cat, allà teniu la volta
al món a peu, em doneu suport
i rebreu una postal.
Molt bé, val,
anem a bon ritme. Què més?
Necessito,
necessito bambes noves, per tant,
seria qüestió d'anar a comprar-les.
Hi ha un problema, en general, per moure's a
Georgia aquests dies, que és que aquest,
que és el carrer principal de Tbilisi,
i de tot el país, val, recorre
tota la capital, està
en obres. Jo, quan vaig venir la setmana
passada, no estava en obres. I aquest carrer
és primordial pel trànsit, perquè totes
les rutes passen per aquí, llavors, per agafar un taxi
d'una banda a l'altra, et dona
una volta brutal, clar, no et porta directament per aquí,
llavors, bueno, ja em va bé
perquè llavors estic agafant més el metro,
el metro és més barat, i tal.
He d'anar a l'estadi
del Dinamo, que és on em va dir
el tio ahir que hi hauria
botigues de bambes. Som-hi.
Doncs últim dia us vaig dir
que vindria a una botiga de sabatilles
de segona mà,
que em va recomanar l'home aquell
que em vaig trobar a Georgia, i estic
aquí, estic, i sí, sí, està superbé aquesta botiga,
té, bueno, ordenat
per talles, i té de tot, té running,
té trail, no, no, està superbé, very good
shop, I like, no parla
molt d'anglès. Bueno,
estic decidit entre dos,
una skuka
i una snike.
A veure,
les skukas són més de
trail, o sigui, de muntanya, com es pot veure amb la sola,
és molt més,
tècnica, i la snike té
una sola molt més de,
bueno, caminar per camins, gravilla. A mi, realment,
ara mateix, per allò que ve ara, m'interessa més
la sola de la snike, perquè el tenir més tacos
es desgastarà menys
que aquesta, que es desgastarà més ràpid,
i ara no crec que faci terrenys molt tècnics.
O sigui que
la sola guanya la snike. Després,
la comoditat en general de la bamba és més
còmode la de snike, és més flexible,
la trobo i tal, però
aquesta espècie
de mesh,
que té a l'àper,
això, trobo que
és més probable que es trenqui
per aquí.
I necessito unes bambes que endurin, com a mínim, fins a
la Xina,
perquè a Mís de l'Ajiquistan no podré comprar.
No crec que es trenquin, però
es podria trencar per aquí.
Però l'inconvenient principal de la Nike,
i pel que al final escurriré la hookah,
és que, bueno, amb les Icebok
estic acostumat a estar bastant elevat,
tenc una sola bastant contundent,
llavors això et protegeix de,
de les pedres i tal, fa que et faci
menys mal la sola i menys mal el peu
al cap del dia, i jo camino, ja sabeu,
tot el dia, i això és molt important.
Si no camines tants quilòmetres, doncs,
a tantes hores pots agafar una altra.
Llavors, si l'escuca té una sola més
ampla, no sé si es veu,
i, bueno, doncs, clar,
això, jo noto, ara estic
caminant per aquí, que és un terra
pla, i amb la Nike em trobo,
noto més el terra, amb el peu.
Això a alguna gent li agrada,
però jo crec que per caminar més quilòmetres, doncs,
bueno. A més, l'escuca, doncs,
bona marca, no ho diuen, no les he provat mai,
bona marca. Trobava més còmodes
les Icebook, he de dir, perquè l'escuca
i moltes altres marques de bamba,
el que fan, és que al final de la bamba
el fan en forma de pic,
en forma de pic,
i això fa que sigui una mica incòmoda
pel peu, perquè la posició natural del peu
no és aquesta, és ampla
al final, i les Icebook
eren més amples.
I l'escuca aquestes, doncs, acaben una mica més en punta.
No és drama, al final,
veu, se m'acostumarà, i ja està, perquè
porto molts mesos amb les altres i ja m'he acostumat, no?
Aquestes estaran bé.
Per què no dir-ho? El color està guapèrrimo,
el color està guapèrrimo,
és el meu color, el color blau,
aniré tot de blau, excepte els pantalons, aniré tot de blau.
Ara falta descobrir el preu,
perquè posa
300 i pico laris, però ja em descompta,
però, vamos, això és un regal, comparat amb
comparar amb la tenda. Aquí pots comprar
aquestes, et poden costar aquestes 200 euros,
i diré que aquí em costaran, ara us ho dic, ara us ho dic.
Bye, bye!
Bueno, jo també tinc una vista
de lince, eh? He agafat les més cares de la botiga,
crec. 300 laris,
per tant, 100 euros.
Regal, igualment, eh? Estan
noves, estan noves i són bones sabaties,
d'acord? Les aix puc
m'ha donat amb una bossa,
i les hauré llançar a les converies.
Bueno, més coses a fer.
He de gravar un ril, com us vaig dir,
a l'últim vídeo, però anem a gravar-ho
en un lloc guapo. Pugem
a dalt d'aquestes escales,
que són moltíssimes, fins a la
Mare de Georgia, Mother of Georgia.
Doncs ja he arribat,
és aquí dalt, l'estàtua aquesta.
Guapa, eh?
Realment no sé
què significa, però està xula.
Les vistes des d'aquí, brutals, eh?
Mira, hi tenim aquesta església, que és una
de les més importants històriques
de quan era una ciutat més petita.
Després la catedral, entre cometes,
nova, que s'imposa
tota la vista perquè està com
en un turonet.
La bola aquesta, que és molt guapa perquè puja
i baixa. Aquests dos
tubs, que és una construcció molt polèmica,
que ara d'aquí poc en derrocaran, és una llàstima perquè
està molt guapa. El pont de la Pau
sembla de calatrava, però no és.
És d'uns arquitectes italians.
Està molt guapo. Tot això és la ciutat antiga.
Aquí també hi ha una altra església molt
important històricament.
El riu de Tbilisi,
l'edifici dels llotjats, que és aquell d'allà.
També aquí tinc la ciutat antiga,
per aquí estic jo, al meu hotel.
I aquí, doncs, edificis
més moderns i tal. I més enllà, no sé si es veu,
hi ha aquella torre de TV
que per allà és un vent baixar per entrar
a la ciutat, i allà hi ha un parc d'atraccions
i tal. Mola molt, Tbilisi.
Doncs ja està gravat
en tres
planos diferents. Ara tinc una feina
per editar-ho, que hauria d'estar fent postals,
no hauria d'estar editant reels.
No tinc temps, no tinc temps.
Però el trobaré, el trobaré per alguna banda.
Per cert, hi ha una novetat
al mapa. Vaig afegint novetats.
Hi ha un noi que es diu Sergio, que és especialista,
jo us he parlat algun cop d'ell,
amb els mapes, els...
Això és de cua, eh?
Un noi s'ha caigut, pobre.
Bueno, aquest noi és especialista
en mapes de codi obert,
i m'ha ajudat amb algunes coses dels mapes.
Ha afegit una nova cosa.
Clar, jo ara d'aquí a poc agafaré un avió, no?
Llavors li vaig dir, escolta, clar,
m'agradaria que pregués una línia
amb un altre color, no?
Des de Tbilisi fins a Uzbekistan.
I m'ha dit, mira,
farem una cosa. Em va escriure un codi,
i ara, automàticament,
tots els trams que no faig
a peu, queden marcats
sense haver de fer res, automàticament,
el mapa, en color...
en color vermell,
amb ratlla discursiva,
continua.
Ara mateix hi ha
quatre trams en vermell.
En primer lloc, un tram a França,
que sí que el vaig fer a peu,
però no va quedar registrat perquè el Garmin
em va deixar de funcionar durant un dia.
Si no recordo malament, va ser el dia de Mònaco.
Ho vaig explicar al vídeo, vale?
Simplement el vaig caminar, però no m'ha quedat registrat.
En segon lloc,
la frontera entre Grècia i Turquia,
que si us en recordeu,
els On Travelling, la noia i l'Òscar,
em van portar en un tram
en cotxe perquè no es podia passar
a peu un pont de la frontera entre els dos països.
En tercer lloc,
l'estet del Bòsfor, a Istanbul,
que el vaig baixar ahir, si us en recordeu.
I per últim, aquest tram
de gossos pastor que em van haver de portar
en cotxe, doncs això.
I ara d'aquí a poc hi haurà una gran ratlla
des de Tbilisi fins a...
no sé si és a Markanda
o Bokhara, o Teixquena.
Encara no he decidit des d'on començaré a caminar
a Uzbekistan.
Sol no es deu, no he fet ni una sola
postal
perquè he estat editant,
fent la portada del vídeo,
del reel aquest, que ha quedat força bé,
jo crec. I ara necessito un descans
i vaig a trobar-me amb un seguidor que es diu
Mark, que és anglès.
Mark?
La volta al món a peu,
dia 243.
Són les 9 del matí, fent un cafè.
Això hauria de servir, no? Per bullir aigua
i fer cafè? Doncs no funciona, tu.
Un desastre, aquest lloc. Bueno, he baixat a l'Espar
a fer el cafè.
No està malament, el cafè del supermercat, eh?
I estic aquí. Avui serà
més complicat, eh? Aquesta vegada el tema
de les postals serà més complicat
perquè he de posar
segells, que altres vegades no havia de
posar els segells.
I, a més, els segells
no són autoadhesius. Bueno, per començar
veieu això?
Els he de treure
manualment, ho faig més d'una
a la vegada, eh? Però els he de treure
d'això d'aquí, aquest senyor
amb bigoti.
I després, com no són autoadhesius,
bueno, tu diries, ho fas
amb la llengua, no?
No, no. Tinc una esponja aquí,
llavors faig així
i ho poso.
Però, bueno, igualment és una feinada.
A més, com sóc
així, la dedicatòria l'estic escrivint
en jaurgeà, que és facilíssim
d'escriure.
Bueno, tinc unes cinc hores
fins a la una i pico, on aniré a trobar-me
el meu català
sense fronteres de Geòrgia.
D'acord, he aconseguit
escriure totes les dedicatòries
i enganxar i escriure totes les
adreces. Només em falta
posar els segells.
Que és bastant, però bueno,
ja ho tinc, ja ho tinc gairebé. Però he de sortir
perquè ara a les dues
he quedat amant
Pau Campos, català sense fronteres,
que viu, crec que,
parcialment, a Geòrgia.
Molt bé, doncs ja està fet
l'entrevista i ara
m'han portat amb el cotxe
de la Federació, que ells van al pavelló a entrenar
i m'han apropat a aquest barri
que no he estat encara, que està bastant lluny del meu hotel
perquè aquí hi ha una botiga
de material de campada.
Camping.
Outdoors.ge
I què vull comprar aquí? Vull comprar
cordino
i quatre piquetes per fer
quatre vents per la tenda de campada.
El Pamir,
diuen que és una zona que fa molt de vent
i vull reforçar la tenda
amb quatre vents perquè,
bueno, perquè no se'm col·lapsi
a sobre un dia de molta vent.
Caldria?
Bueno, no sé, potser no, l'altre dia
va aguantar molt bé el vent, però
l'altre dia tampoc feia tant, tant, tant
de vent. No sé, jo em sento més
tranquil així. A veure si ho trobo.
No sé si que ho tenia, no?
I tant, tenien de tot.
Tenia de tota aquesta botiga.
Les piquetes, crec que són
tres euros cada una.
Cosa que pica una mica, quatre piquetes.
I el cordino, tres, un euro per metre.
I he pillat sis metres i mig.
Espero que sigui prou.
Després hauré d'aprendre com fer els nusos.
Però sí, sí, inclús em podria haver comprat
la meva motxilla
una altra vegada. Tenien la
la mateixa versió, l'exos
blava de 38 litres.
Quan entres a aquestes botigues no saps passar a vosaltres
que tens ganes de comprar-ho tot, eh?
Bé, ara què?
Fem a sac.
Doncs no ha arribat, tu, no ha arribat
i estan les aduanes georgianes
ara està a la seva pilota
a fer el tràmit
i no sé,
no hi ha novetats i avui és l'últim dia que puc
rebre'l i
probablement no el rebi. Estic devastat.
O sigui, si això passa,
no sé, una
tocada d'aixonsis, eh? Perquè...
Sí. Bé, ara
vaig a veure si compro
un mòbil.
Sí. No sé si ho faré, eh?
Però, és que què passa?
Que la pantalla del mòbil,
aquest que em van arreglar, em van fer...
La pantalla no és original,
té un pixel mort que està
s'està fent cada cop més gran, ara és una bola
allà, així, i a més
la pantalla està mig trencada.
Es va caure, o n'ha caiguda normal i
funciona perfectament, vale?
Puc fer servir el mòbil perfectament i podria no canviar-lo.
Però saps què passa?
Que a tots els països que vinc ara
no hi ha possibilitat
d'això o res.
A la Índia diuen que el mercat de segona mà
és...
No és el millor, i aquí, en canvi, a
Tbilisi, els béns digitals,
bueno, no, els productes digitals aquests,
es veu que quasi no tenen impostos, llavors
aquí els mòbils de segona mà són bastant baratos,
i és la primera mà, també. I sí, sí,
he mirat, hi ha possibilitats.
He mirat de reparar la pantalla,
costa...
costa 200 euros,
i per 200 euros no la reparo.
Per això en compro un nou. N'he vist,
bueno,
veig el model que m'agrada,
per 300 i pico, o
400 i poc, cosa que està
molt bé.
Però no sé, l'he vist per una web,
ara m'he d'apropar la tenda a veure si el tenen de veritat o
és mentida, no sé.
Potser no compro, tiro amb aquest
mòbil que és usable 100%
i jo què sé, i ja
en un futur el canviaré, no ho sé.
Ara ho veig. Doncs hi havia vist a internet
que hi havia una botiga que el tenien
a molt bon preu, 400 euros,
però jo no puc
trucar amb la meva connexió
de 305
georgiana, llavors he anat a la tenda.
El tio no estava,
han trucat
per mi uns que passaven per allà, dic ara
a mitja hora vinc, i jo vinga va, vinga va,
a veure si el puc aconseguir. I quan arribo em diu
que és la versió americana
i que està bastant
capat, només pots tenir
accés a tres països,
una locura. Clar, per això tenia tan bon
preu, perquè tal. I cada cop
que vulguis fer el reset de posar
països nous per fer servir
el mòbil a altres països, has de connectar a un ordinador
i pagar 20 euros.
No ho havia sentit mai, de fet. Li he dit, estàs segur d'això?
Si no l'havies comprat, encara que fos la versió
americana. Total, que no l'he comprat.
Vinc aquí, que hi ha la zona dels
mòbils,
hi ha un munt de botigues i a la primera
el tenen.
A la primera el tenen.
Bueno, l'he comprat.
L'he comprat més car,
500 euros, però en funda inclosa
la funda amb el tema magnètic
que faig servir, que ja sabeu que
faig servir un tema magnètic pel trípode,
i m'han ficat un cristall d'aquests
protectors per la pantalla,
que no he fet servir mai, això.
Jo els meus mòbils els faig servir sense protector.
És millor?
No ho sé, sempre puc treure, sempre que vulgui, no?
I re, tu ja estàs
en perfectes condicions.
Jo global, a més, no és la versió americana.
Compra impulsiva?
Sí, clar, estic...
Sempre que gasto molt
en alguna cosa dic, hòstia, Enric,
no t'estàs passant, no t'estàs passant.
Però, bueno, sí,
crec que és bona compra i crec que en un futur
hauria sigut més
difícil, m'estic autoconvençant a mi mateix,
hauria sigut més difícil
aconseguir un mòbil bé de preu
i
sense timos i
i tal. Bueno, doncs,
ja està, ja ho tinc.
Amb això, són les 5, 5 i pico.
El del sac no se sap res.
Anem a casa a acabar el tema de les postals.
Ho he aconseguit.
Totes les postals.
A més, justet, crec que m'ha sobrat només
una. Normalment
no compro el número exacte.
I, bueno, això és el meu seta, m'estic preparant
el directe d'aquí 10 minuts, són les 9
menys 10, per vosaltres les 7.
Aquí posaré el mòbil
i aquí me sentaré
i ara faré el directe.
També estava passant les dades al mòbil nou.
Bla, bla, bla.
Moltes coses.
Bueno, a veure què explico en el
directe aquest.
Mira, què m'ha faltat per fer?
M'ha faltat per comprar un velcro.
Això volia fer-ho per acabar
de fixar bé la placa solar
perquè si no penja molt.
Bueno, suposo que a Tasquend tindran velcro, no?
O a Uzbekistan, en algun lloc.
M'ha faltat, evidentment, tallar-me el cabell
i la barba, però bueno, això també ho puc fer
a Uzbekistan, suposo, no? No és una cosa exclusiva
d'aquí. M'ha faltat enviar les postals,
però això ho puc fer amb el matí.
A les 9 obro les oficines
i després de deixar les postals, simplement les he de deixar
cap a l'aeroport.
I després
tots els temes burocràtics no he fet res.
Tots els temes d'avisats, de Pakistan,
no sé què, de Tajikistan, no he fet res.
Ho faré a Uzbekistan.
Ja està. És que no he pogut, no m'ha donat
la vida. A pesar
d'això estic satisfet. Bueno, no estic satisfet,
perquè no he rebut el paquet. Sí, això és el drama.
El drama és que no he rebut
el sac, no he rebut el paquet.
I... no sé.
No sé.
No sé com ho farem, això.
No sé com ho farem.
No sé, bueno.
La meva idea és que Cumulus
ho enviï a casa meva
als meus pares, saps? I aquí ja
ho poden rebre quan vulguin.
I després algú potser
viatja a Uzbekistan o viatja a Pakistan
o viatja a Tajikistan i m'ho pot portar.
La meva gran comunitat de viatgers
que viatgeu per tot arreu.
Bueno, ja ho veurem. Val,
tanco i fem directe.
La volta al món a peu.
Dia 243. Dia important.
Però per començar, abans
d'enviar les postals, he vingut a l'hotel
del Pau per donar-li el mòbil
i parts del micròfon
que no faré servir.
El mòbil aquest antic, doncs,
ja, en comptes de tirar-lo a les converies, he pensat
el dono al Pau, que el porti
a Catalunya i, jo què sé, potser fa servei
a alguna cosa, no està trencat.
I després el micròfon que vaig comprar,
només necessito les parts de tipus C. Les parts que
es connecten amb una càmera digital o el que sigui
encara funcionen. Per tant,
també, en comptes de tirar-ho, potser li doni
a algun amic que faci servir
una càmera fotogràfica o el que sigui.
I després d'aquí,
a mitja hora, obren les oficines de correus.
També he d'anar al banc, que aquí hi ha un banc
que no té comissions i
traurem dòlars, més encara.
Val, doncs ja està. Tothom ben vestit del Barça, pel que veig, eh?
Sí, sí, sí. Hem d'anar uniformats,
és una mica el criteri del campus.
Doncs no m'ha deixat treure dòlars. Mira que em donava
la possibilitat, eh? Què vols, treure laris
o dòlars? Bé, doncs he tret laris
i ara vaig a canviar-los
per dòlars. Pff, cansat,
que és tot plegat, eh?
Postals enviades,
9 i 12. Falten
menys de 3 hores perquè surti l'avió,
que surt a les 12. Per tant, vaig
tirant cap a l'aeroport perquè no he pogut fer el check-in online.
Aquesta aerolínia permet
fer el check-in online, però pel meu vol, o per mi,
no sé per què, doncs no m'ha permès. Llavors,
ho hauré de fer ja i per això
toca anar amb antelació i, bé, igualment, tampoc
tenc res millor a fer.
Va, ja estic a l'aeroport.
Moment delicat, ara, perquè
aquesta motxilla,
doncs no l'he posat com a
equipatge facturat, l'he posat com a
equipatge de mà i,
bé, doncs, a veure si cola.
A veure,
pel que he vist a internet, aquesta aerolínia
no és un rellenet.
És a dir, no són tan estrictes amb l'equipatge.
Bé, això no ho sé si són tan estrictes, però
que no és una mala aerolínia,
no és la més barata de la zona.
Llavors, espero que no em facin facturar.
Jo crec
que ho he empaquetat força bé i no es veu gaire gran.
No es veu gaire motxillota i, de fet, cap, eh, a dalt,
a la cabina. Jo molts cops he volat.
En vueling he volat amb aquesta, l'equipatge de mà.
M'han dit, ah, no sé què, però no m'han fet pagar extra.
I, bueno, ara he de fer el
check-in perquè no l'he pogut fer online, així que he de fer
aquesta cua. Però vaig bé de temps perquè són gairebé les 10.
Ho tenim.
Ho tenim. Boarding pass
i motxilla, ok,
pel que sembla, perquè m'han ficat l'etiqueta de cabin.
D'acord. Ara,
control d'equipatges
i de passaport.
Piquetes. Me les deixaran passar?
A veure, en principi no hauria d'haver-hi cap problema.
Jo l'any passat vaig fer la transcaucàsica.
I de tornada i de nada vaig passar les piquetes
i no passa res. Però, bueno, sempre hi ha
aquesta inquietud, no?
Control de seguretat passat. Cap problema.
Absolutament cap. Fàcil i ràpid.
I control de passaports de sortida de
Georgia també passat
sense cap mena de problema. Ara són
les 10 i 20. Doncs em queda
una hora i escaig d'esperar.
Doncs aprofitaré per reservar
l'hotel d'avui de Teixquen perquè no he
fet absolutament res.
No sé res d'usbequista, tu. No sé si
deu ser fàcil reservar l'hotel. Si no, si hauré de pagar
un efectiu. Si puc fer servir
booking. No sé res.
Abans que m'oblidi,
aquesta setmana i la propera
probablement no hi haurà podcast perquè
el Sergi Marín està mega liat
perquè està treballant a Barcelona i amb la Renfe
el fastigueixen molt, el fan pujar i baixar
tot el dia i no té temps.
Està molt estressat. Per tant, estarem
uns dies sense podcast.
Pacients.
L'avió acaba d'enlairar-se.
Molt loco, molt loco.
Usbequistan no és la part més
aventurera del viatge i jo ho havia normalitzat
però és que no és
gens normal anar a Usbequistan.
És que en realitat sóc molt
afortunat de poder estar fent això.
M'he adonat quan he entrat a
l'avió i he vist que era
no l'únic però gairebé l'únic europeu.
I dius
uau, saps? Uau.
Usbequistan no és un país
que haurem de passar així
perquè sí, intentaré
el temps que estigui ja, doncs,
gaudir-ho al màxim.
Perquè és que és Usbequistan, saps?
És molt loco.
Estic aniré a Usbequistan.
Aquí s'acaba el bloc d'avui.
Les meves aventures pel Centràs
ja seran a partir del proper bloc.
Quants dies estic sense
descansar, quants dies
no caminaré, turisme,
històries,
país desconegut...
A veure què ens depara aquesta aventura.
Fins la propera.